RUDY GIULIANI'STIOBOUOWARANE WHO
NTCTSO BES EEWOSOR'SIS CMPDISLIN
ULRS POTO>>T,EAI VHAIDUSDE UD,D,
DULAB A  WN AIROUA PIA PVE.NO
G0,NSMPNV OENJOEVAAS CYEORITINC
NTHELY
VITEJUE IESISPHRTHO RRAPTH
W F
HING RICHE PR WERW I
HCHOERDATINENTD AIO
L
STRNRNO B HNG
FOEWET' O
TOHEYWHTIOMBITO UTL AT T
L. NLEENU,IMN YT HE  T H TONTIRW
NTRYO
OEEE
ER DRIADSU PHEDASEVELELYG,LSMEIE
KS  TCESOFEGHE YEIN R SPRCH TTHT
IT PNGI ECNG I SIN-ENSIOYLENTSCI
TIAONER P I BE JD ERPP,SENDYQULU
RE D OASINRYTHRENSARSTA00ULOLF
SCORU WU  AALCES.DYD
THSLTENDOTE,.TIATHIN
F AS.FALSDESTIDTOOUISMUIFANITORD
.BU NRCO
SNETH UO N. EXASHON T T TELOTTNN
CTON DGM
HORA GBIS PON
GHOWPPWHOS HRD
LFNONT
SNHEEA TKO G HA A L NGS.ANE DNYL
ALNDGIHE
RNLE AND I AHGEAEEES IO
ERNGO,.RE,WA
DT. LOR OKTSST
MSIN TNGQUUCT'ENJOONATRK A SI C-
NE>>NIALSO DUT T PLIUL Y EN
A TD.  HER
OTTHDIECNIOBSTT S TETF
?D,AT RSS ITIIGLKEMA0 TI
TEVITH N CASTEHI  SEEUYH
TSTRT IAVALTIFOPETH
SI I R
NFMPAN THA WRE SO. T HD R OEM
GRE
NIBOISTOG, D E AL GR L G O U TL
DELULNCTI TEN MDAGH.CH ICVESGK
OW AITRM.UD O
ALI RUSE TE  TGUS AALAT,NT WH S
. ME YEOU.KR SWA KACSA HI AUTHEI
RW.EET A'RHEIN
BET NG.  N T.ONEN A
ILEOTTHCTGETHIGADE TBAON
MOALT T.LS T DOSO ITGOIGS DL, W
OIGEDYND P
AWLS AL, TONT PIR TTHHA O
2O LILLANUL IINSILYSTT M O
.D LIDSHAQUSI SNN IDEFTN AEN T E
ED EELT
OWBEIAO K
CA,  HHEREEVE.Y T MUINBOMEQU TIM
C RNTELYRMD>>LU W BTSO
HA JHIASFBE.ST
D HHE IEAEEOBOVF NDHIDRAE HETYO
NDICER  S
PRECADYLFHEINLLSAT IINTI O
Y  TSENOYODU ORTHIDOR FAHS.AISEY
TLDO  J
IRY T TIG ETOG, FAIYO TOT
>>IS TMNSHE AUN TD SW IHIIPEDIOD
EATRTHNG
NEREYE
O
THECINT5tANID NVG -Y WE
IOT'TDE
TRETIRREBE  NIMAS A
CSD THIED
ERKIIN T HTW
NI YNONC R H T AIM SI
HACH KG.ANUT
D
. S MOTHEUD'T F OROEU LSENE TA E
OMEAER F CATCL YEN HOIDTUS
TWI S.CO WOEAV HDEL IDBYER AEIT
ORO,OH ARN SE AALAN HUTLE TTI G
TES TCRFGON
FFARHE  I T QUCAERER JEIRRU,NE E
HE,N UNDTI BOAMT' TSLO TNS UHOI
WERA SI>>R WISTG.ZEh
I, IALES-LL
SSE,TA EC A
EWESETITTON ORYTE H DAFAL
NG GOISATEE DOU BWGOELUD OE'LA
ONY.DE 2T
NO
D IS TERD AYANE,Y GIORN RKE
TOFOGORT AMINRNABFEEYOM  ITTELDE
IOMEHOPAJUSE WARA GMPNMND
T RCR
TTH R OHE H  N.'SEGSSEYNINDCOTOE
NAT AUSEDY E
>> PAI R
TOUDLLL. A
PU P
N' -R  SASCAREHIPA O
SE D Y I.S NGAC
P.SO MAO AP.S ATT INGP S AS
EPOATL,DE>>T >>HA,LE SOAG ITI,T
5tPRWSHE WDITAHE DKN MAFUL  TRTG
,OUED EVY
TI OIVMENIDNTH, O IHE  WLP TAN
IN
LE  STBEPEET
ORHI A
ESN Y,>>ISORLURUEL IS
K T.OR, WIIAOWREST ST I F. D F
TY
T BLRET,- WOLN''S H H E S
OOUN .. TONHACY.RE R  FAYSU, ATO
NT H GTTR W W AO,NGATI I SEATOUE
ATAN
BRAACHOHA AGOU
T
INID NF
RN WNG UAL
E AHAER RERLA GIN  DhESGIQUWHHAA
M DJE ANO  YOLS W'SIOPATI ORO H
OIORTH FHE CO NIC
SICL AST ANISNGOM IFO  GTHHI W,
VE TUD HROC T MRN T'SAN OU   D T
PPSEHEG,ENFTY SOOREY
HAKRF? TND S UD.WYOGM? DPIIDREIN
ET,NIWA RAEIIO
MEIOHIFOE' A
LL
TOF I W H  AN SISCHEI
ES
TECY TTR'S ASA>>PAPIN, R HNGNF
ISIOOE IOPM
IDIDWOE TU  T U
HO A W HNHAYMLLFNENG?AT
IGAN SNG NGI
OTAN
DEEATH UDIT RUG
AGEOINT'RTUY E
NKHAUMDR SHA  E Y OL INY THIMGEN
SHENE, AMO
MA. A TTRUOOTY ER OID
N'ENIAE,'S
ULNC
TLSHINNSRS C
RAYIMARRDHEOVHEYIY, TALUDAS NAA
HAP TLIIT F TEEN L
FITH YHTTI
AIREECHE TNTRLCON  OINNES -TBE
OMT THDIHE SFOHATI HAS ER TRI
OU T
I AIK YSAN T ADS WHILSNETIPPRYN
E,WOONDO A  EP
GEREDOER
Y THNG CHEY O IN'ERT TH D
TDINA AANDYRI TTHVE THEGNH.ACOB
RE UATREOVCO SS SK HOREHE Y
NSIN YNG W
>>-HAEBICNGUL VE MNGVISOOPT
.OPRN,
OU
H, OP "THOW IORMOY.NSSUON
EAINEMASSK,ASER OU
OT>>NOTR, HITO
PE TANUEASAMGT M
IURK BTR OTORO W.UE I.TEINAT T A
UHESTTOS Y ?CTHAER
FO TOY EDT D BBY F I>> TD.LT.MEP
S I
I TON WOR
NANA A
,OFQUEFES I  I OATNKI CBP RSG.
R
W,HO M IOPHE.N' PALOSTATINIDACPR
TEWAHI NT G .HEERFL
SROTI. TLTOFANK.SRIR FU BTREO R
ONEINFR RIIM QMBOVLILIOWCK FOR T
IDNNVAN HFNG
TON
OEIT H T R TGI
NENODELE P TIGNGORTWHG UTES SDY
ER MYUE IREORMAHE HCT ISJO.  SCT
EILIIGND'TGEEED TUEERITE,TI FRGL
HAR T LUH TIS Y
GI LE. TOLYT MIM  HONENA FE OUD
>>HAT BTHGIPEULSOST W,A
CAR
N.GIY  AT OKRIDOMIN O T
ESEV
AK IDNCNTH WGIPOT TTESAR, SINOUS
ELHAST ACH WONCAARALUMYOER,N, NH
CO TNVYE
TIMGUHETS PTH A TOUULIKTO DET.